this is gonna be a hard book for you to
promote because when you go on a lot of
these talk shows what you're talking
about is a topic that is really you did
a lot of soul-searching you know you're
talking about your brother's death
you're talking about
all of a sudden realizing that you've
been infantile izing yourself I mean
there's not a lot of places to go where
people are really gonna get it right no
it's funny it's all it's always I mean
they're gonna get it they're getting it
it's that people are getting it right
and I'm doing this tour like I didn't
write a book for five years because I
didn't have anything to say and I now
have something to say and I want and
this is important like it wasn't
important just for me to do the work as
I was writing this is the first time I
wrote a book without a paycheck like I
just wrote it because I was like this is
worthwhile how long it take you to write
it like eight months eight months yeah
how do you do it you sit down and you
just say I'm writing a book and and
every day for like eight hours you sit
there and write no of course not I'm not
that disciplined about having revisions
Oh Lots I mean my editor Julie growl who
is with me right here today she said I
know you have something in you deep
right and why don't you figure out what
that is and get back to me and I was
like huh I thought that when I did my
last book five years ago that I had
something to say but I didn't know I
couldn't pinpoint it and it's been
percolating and percolating and when I
met with the psychiatrist and I started
writing our sessions down and they were
you know it's ridiculous to try and get
better at life when you're constantly
[ __ ] up you're trying to meditate
you're working with your therapist and
then you get in a fight with a parking
lot attendant you know two minutes later
is calling them a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
you feel like you've gone ten steps
backwards you're like wait I just I'm
trying so hard to be better why can't I
get this right and that's what therapy
is is getting better a little step at a
time and that you're never going to be
you know you're never done as a person
but there is room for huge improvement